on va tout de suite rejoindre France
bellile qui est la mairesse de Gatineau
bonsoir
bonsoir Monsieur Fillon c'est quand même
impressionnant chez vous un taux
d'inoccupation de 0,8 % on dit que c'est
la ville la plus chère pour les
locataires comment vous décrivez la
situation chez vous
la situation du logement et les
problèmes natiques inquiétantes
préoccupantes
urgentes il faut s'y attaquer il faut
s'y attaquer ensemble dans la lettre
vous faisiez référence qui a été publié
aujourd'hui envoyé au Premier ministre
c'est significatif et absolument pas
banal qu'on a des gens du privé du
communautaire et des élus qui
interpellent le gouvernement pour qu'on
s'assoit à la table tout le monde
ensemble je pense qu'on veut tous la
même chose on veut que les gens aient un
toit sur la tête on va être capable de
penser à toutes sortes de type de
logements pour toutes sortes de titres
de clientèle mais à l'heure actuelle
c'est très difficile à Gatineau non zéro
point 8 c'est 0 alors c'est très très
difficile pour une personne qui est en
recherche de logements à l'heure
actuelle à une chambre d'accoucher c'est
autour de 1700 dollars deux chambres à
coucher 2000 dollars alors qu'est-ce que
ça provoque si vous avez de l'argent
vous vous en tirez pas mal si vous êtes
assez Chan pour vous trouver une place
et si vous n'avez pas d'argent vous
coupez partout ailleurs alors il y a de
la pression sur les banques alimentaires
il y a des gens qui sont des gens à
faibles revenus qui se retrouvent
itinérant à la rue parce qu'ils ne sont
pas capables de payer et dans une autre
situation mais Gatineau se retrouve à
l'heure actuelle avec un campement qui
compte une soixantaine de temps une
combinaison d'itinérance chronique mais
aussi des tinérances situations
bien sûr qu'on s'inquiète on s'inquiète
du premier juillet on est en discussion
avec nos partenaires mais en même temps
vous savez des mises en chantier ça se
fait pas en criant de ciseaux c'est pour
ça que ça nous prend un plan il faut que
tout le monde soit autour de la table si
j'étais le premier ministre je me
réjouirai de voir qu'il y a des gens de
tout leur exemple qui veulent s'asseoir
avec lui pour être capable de trouver
des solutions il y a aussi des choses
qui font mal au cœur monsieur Fillon
j'en ai parlé dans d'autres entrevues
vous savez quand on aimerait souvenir
d'une ville au Québec on est en première
ligne moi chaque matin que je vais aller
hôtel de ville je vois ces temps-là qu'à
chaque soir que je rentre chez nous je
vois des gens qui attendent durant deux
coins de rue pour en espérant qu'ils
vont être capable de rentrer à la
surpopulaire alors il y a des
juridictions on entend souvent les gens
du terrain dire là c'est une bataille de
gouvernement c'est vrai que c'est ça
même un moment donné on est en train de
parler des humains puis d'un toit sur la
tête qu'est-ce que je sache on est
encore dans la pyramide de Maslow d'un
Québec qui a des valeurs il faudrait
commencer s'occuper de notre monde puis
le faire tout le monde ensemble est-ce
que ce message là
avez-vous l'impression qu'il est entendu
à Québec la part du gouvernement de
François Legault
moi j'ai eu des échanges avec madame
duransault je peux vous dire que j'ai
senti une souplesse une ouverture de la
part de la ministre même pour Gatineau
on a demandé dans un programme qu'elle
fasse preuve d'agilité puis on a discuté
avec son cabinet ça nous a donné un coup
de main il faut aller encore plus loin
c'est à dire qu'il y a de la souplesse
il y a des coûts qui explorent alors que
les programmes sont parfois figés dans
des critères qui nous limitent il y a
aussi une discussion à avoir sur la
contribution du privé les
investissements dans le social
communautaire ça prend un grand plan
national puis ça faut le faire tout le
monde ensemble puis on peut plus
attendre parce qu'on a trop attendu
alors il faut vraiment se mettre au
travail le plus vite possible et quel
est le rôle des municipalités dans ça
je vous dirais de jouer en fait
d'assumer un lit deux chips et de porter
la voix de ce qu'on voit au quotidien et
je pense que si on est au gouvernement
du Québec à la province on doit être
capable de reconnaître que les maires
les maires et les villes sont en
première ligne les besoins de nos
citoyens au quotidien on les entend
c'est nous autres qui viennent voir au
conseil municipal pour nous dire que ça
marche ça marche pas alors je pense
qu'on est des acteurs privilégiés on a
un les deux chiffres à voir on est des
recommandations à faire on se positionne
pas un chien des solutions on en or
voudrait des amener à la table il faut
que le gouvernement du Québec soit
capable de voir ça il faut qu'on soit
capable d'avancer vous savez la question
de l'itinérance est un partiellement
relié au logement est extrêmement
problématique à l'heure actuelle et
comme on est dans une émission
économique il faut aussi considérer tout
l'impact économique quand on n'a pas de
logement c'est des étudiants qui
viennent pas étudier à l'université du
Québec en Outaouais qui viennent pas au
cégep c'est on prive donc nos
entreprises de main d'oeuvre parce qu'on
n'est pas capable de développer de la
relève il y a tout un temps qui est
économique et qui ne se limite pas
strictement à avoir un toit sur la tête
ou à la question de l'itinérance bien
qu'elle soit très importante qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec les immigrants qu'on
veut attirer par exemple dans nos
communautés donc c'est beaucoup plus
grand que l'impact simplement d'avoir un
toit sur la tête c'est toutes l'économie
qui se trouve structurée ou
déstructurées par le fait qu'on ait un
logement ou non alors c'est un cri du
coeur et je l'entends bien de votre part
d'ailleurs France Belle-Île merci merci
d'avoir été avec nous c'était très clair
merci
bonsoir merci de m'avoir invité pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]